[Musique]
où
selon une légende du haut moyen-âge la
tribu des francs tiendrait son origine
de la cité de 3 en asie mineure
cette solide croyances durera jusqu'à la
renaissance et même au delà
c'est dans l'iliade que le poète grec au
maire raconte le siège de troie par les
achéens venus de la mer là en 1300 avant
notre ère s'affrontent les héros aux
armes de bronze
achille et hector l'enjeu la possession
de la belle hélène
sous le regard des roi agamemnon et
priam et sous le rire des dieux de
l'olympe
[Musique]
après dix ans de siège infructueux
l'ingénieuse ulysse fait construire un
immense cheval de bois montés sur roues
[Musique]
pensant qu'il s'agit d'une offrande
les troyens tir dans leur ville la
statue géante
[Musique]
e
mais c'est un piège à la faveur de la
nuit du ventre creux du cheval vont
surgir des soldats zac est un qui
s'empare de la ville par surprise
vaincus hillion sont râleurs dans les
flammes et la plupart de ses habitants
périssent de ce brasier ne réchappe que
quelques survivants promis toutefois à
une prolifique postérité beaucoup de
peuples européens revendiquent en effet
un héros troyen comme fondateur de leur
nation est née à fonder rome
france ix on a fondé la france est
brutus la bretagne
les scandinaves ont assimilé 3 à leur
mythique cité 2000 garde
porté par un mystérieux tropisme de tous
les horizons d'europe on se voit en fils
héritier de la cité du roi priam c'était
aussi le cas des celtes payen il y à
ammien marcellin est un historien majeur
de l'antiquité tardive dans son oeuvre
en parallèle des événements de son temps
il donne de précieuses informations sont
les croyances des pop
concernant les celtes il dit sont
référés à team agem un historien grec du
1er siècle avant notre ère donc du temps
de l'indépendance gauloise et des
druides selon une coutume fréquents chez
les païens la tribu prétend descendre
d'un héros légendaire peuples
autochtones les saltos tiendrait ainsi
leur nom d'un ancien roi qui devait
s'appeler celle tos aux galates s
les grecs ont rapproché ce roi de leurs
dieux et recule dans ces contrées
certains semble-t-il s'affirme
autochtones ont l'église celle du nom
d'un bon roi et galates du nom de sa
mère en langue grecque
on les appelle galles d'autres affirment
que ce sont des dorés acquis à la suite
des reculs l'ancien serait venu habiter
ces lieux voisins de l'océan
l'enseignement des druides se fait plus
précis une partie du peuple celte est
certes autochtones mais une autre partie
ne l'est pas ces étrangers serait venu
dit le lointaines ou d'outre-rhin
ayant eu vent de la légendaire bataille
de trois les bardes gardien de la
mémoire ethnique de la gaule firent le
rapprochement selon un
ces étrangers d'outre-rhin auraient été
des survivants troyens qui après la
chute de leur cité avait trouvé le salut
en gaule les druides mentionne de source
sûre qu'une partie du peuple est
indigène n'est que l'autre à confluer
dit le lointaine et de migration doutre
rats chassés de leurs foyers par
l'abondance des guerres et par les
débordements de la mer
certains disent qu'après la chute de
troie une poignée de troyens fuyant les
grecs partout dit céline et va occuper
ces lieux alors désert les habitants de
ces contrées affirme en particulier et
nous l'avons lu gravés sur le monument
qu'hercule fils d'amphitryon avait
précipité la perte des cruelles tyran
gérions et au risque qui ravageait klein
l'espagne l'autre la gaule et qu il
s'unit avec des femmes très noble dont
il eut nombre d'enfants chacun de
ceux-ci ayant appelé de son nom la
partie qu'il avait à gouverner
d'autres auteurs font aussi état de
cette origine troyenne des celtes
notamment sidoine apollinaire un auteur
gaulois en 471 sidoine est évêque de
clairement en auvergne en se plaignant
des temps barbares dont souffre alors sa
région il rappelle les glorieuses
légende locale
il assimile la légende de l'origine
troyenne non offrant qu'il connaît
pourtant pour en avoir côtoyé mais aux
anciens celte
ici les arvernes l' esclavage des
arvernes aux douleurs -qui six jeux sont
de la passe est posée jadis se dire
frères des latins et reporter l'origine
de leur peuple au sandillon la mémoire
ethnique de la gaule a donc conservé des
récits païens qui font état d'une
ancienne migrations en provenance dit le
lointaine d'outre-rhin et de la cité de
ce sont ces légendes celtiques qui se
sont greffées sur les premiers chef des
francs la greffe a pris d'autant plus
facilement que les francs viennent eux
mêmes d'une région rhénane les vieilles
chronique de france font en effet
remonter l'origine de la royauté
française aprilia le roi des troyens
selon la chronique de frais des guerres
daté du 7e siècle
à l'origine les freins sûrs pour premier
roi priam ensuite selon ce qui est écrit
dans les livres l'histoire ils eurent
pour roy frigga le héros éponyme qui
porte en lui les germes de la nation
française se nomme frigga france yon où
franck us
adapté au nom des francs il est
l'équivalent du roi cette hausse
ancien héros éponyme des celtes
après l'effondrement de 3 les rescapés
entame un longue exode à travers terre
et mer une partie par faire souche en
macédoine sous ce nom les ancêtres
d'alexandre le grand
l'autre partie derrière son roi france
ix on pousse plus loin sa route
les francs remonte le danube
[Musique]
sur leurs chariots il chevauche à
travers les plaines boueuse et gagne
l'europe centrale
sept autres partis en effet s'avança
depuis la phrygie à travers moult région
déserte avec femme et enfants comme ils
avaient élu à roye du nom de france ix
on sait de lui qu on les appela les
francs on dit de france ion qu'il était
très courageux à la guerre et que l'otan
il batailla avec matt peuple sa cage à
une partie de l'asie puis se tournant
vers l'europe
il alla s'établir entre le rhin et le
danube et la mer une partie des francs
décide alors de faire souche en pannonie
il se met sous l'autorité d'un roi nommé
d'orco de torts co ce rennais le
mystérieux peuple des torts qu en
troisième le peuple des torque est issu
de la même origine selon la tradition
après que les francs pur traverser
l'asie se livrant à un acte de guerre et
qu'ils eurent a lancé en europe sur les
rives du danube entre la trace et
l'océan
une partie d'entre eux demeurent à la il
élu roi du nom de porco par lequel on
nomma le peuple des torque qui sont les
torque malgré l'homonymie il ne peut
s'agir des turcs car les turcs peuples
asiatiques n'entre dans l'histoire qu'à
la fin du 6e siècle
il ne peut non plus agir d un installé
en pannonie car les uns étaient bien
connus et n'ont jamais reçu le nom de
torque
leroy orco et son peuple tort qu on plus
avoir semble-t-il avec la mythologie
celtique
[Musique]
dans le côté on druidique il y avait un
dieu au sanglier
or en gaulois sangliers se dit turc
hausse une statue antique présent un
dieu de forme humaine avec un sanglier
gravé sur le trou l'homme porte autour
du cou un collier typique des celtes qui
se nomme torque août orco en gaulois on
devine impossible jeu de mots concernant
ce dieu à la fois lié aux sangliers turc
hausse et portant un thorpe torgau dans
le langage des droïdes pour désigner un
dieu on a ajouté un suffixe comme this
pour indiquer l'appartenance par exemple
la tribu se disant tout à le dieu de la
tribu se nomme toutatis sur cette base
le sanglier se disant turc hausse
le dieu aux sangliers se nommait peut
être turc otis d'où les noms de torts co
et de sa tribu éponyme les torqx
il existait un dieu sangliers chez les
sectes
c'est ce dieu sangliers que l'on
retrouve au pays de galles sous le nom
de tourc'h tweet connu pour dévasté les
terres du roi arthur
les francs se divise alors en deux
groupes ceux qui refusent de rester avec
torts qu en pannonie reprennent l'exode
avec france ion et gagne la vallée du
rhin les francs poussèrent l'heure pas
avec femmes et enfants sans qu'aucun pas
que mes pneus résisté répondant mais
après le nombreuses luttes
quand ils s'établirent sur le rhin ayant
été diminués par tort qu ils n'étaient
plus qu'une petite troupe
les raisons de la scission entre france
ion et orco sont inconnus
mais la mémoire ethnique le racing
déroule différents
pension étant le chef légitime et
victorieuse à la guerre c'est de lui que
les fronts tiennent leur nom tort qu au
contraire apparaît comme un presse
séditieux qui aura affaibli les francs
[Musique]
une fois parvenus dans la vallée du rhin
les francillon racines et le roi france
y ont ils fait bâtir une vaste cité en
mémoire de l'ancien 3 avec le roi france
y ont une partie parcouru l'europe et
avec femme et enfants vient occuper les
rives du rap à côté du rhin à la
ressemblance de 3 et ensemble ont ils
entreprirent d'édifier une cité elle fut
certes prises mais il en reste l'ouvragé
inachevé le nom de troie qui se dit trop
ya trop jeunes ou trop bien on latin
médiéval a pu être confondu localement
avec la colonia trajane à une ville
frontière édifier le long du rhin par
l'empereur trajan en lançant de notre
ère à la fin de l' empire
ces ruines encore imposante pouvait
laisser croire à la présence de l'a3
jadis construite par france y ont l'idée
d'une nouvelle 3 bâti par les francs
revient souvent dans les comics
la plupart des auteurs lassitude
toutefois nous le long du rhin mais sur
les bords du danube et elle porte un nom
si qu'henri
le livre de l'histoire des francs est
une chronique du viiie siècle
elle raconte en détail le parcours et
l'installation des francs assis qu'ambri
à leur départ de 3 ce qui allait devenir
les francs n'était encore qu'une petite
tribu dont l'armée s'élevait à 12 mille
soldats sur leur navire france ion et
son peuple longe le bosphore pénètre
dans la mer noire et remonte le danube
jusqu'à la plaine de pannonie en
pannonie france y ont font de la cité de
sic en gris ce puissant château fera la
gloire dé francs
l'élévation d'une telle forteresse
mobilise tous les corps de métiers
tailleur de pierre forgeron du ch dron
charpentier meunier chaque homme a à
coeur l'amour du bel ouvrage et
participe au bien commun
le maître transmet son savoir faire à
l'apprenti
[Musique]
sur plusieurs générations la tribu
construit son monde cette forteresse et
ciel
avec le temps la prospérité fleury si
cambre il surgit du sol et le peuple des
france accroît considérablement après
avoir pénétré le marais mais aussi d'
sur leur navire il part vaart aux
limites de la pannonie qui jouxte le
marais et commencèrent d'édifier une
cité en leur mémoire qui doit plaire si
quand même les habits terre de
nombreuses années et se multiplièrent
d'un grand peuple
l'oeuf troyen n'est plus mais le pr
france ix on érige les remparts de sic
en brie berceau de la lignée royale des
francs au xvième siècle le poète on sort
s'adresse ainsi à france ion toi parvenu
vers la froide parti ou la hongrie est
jointe à la city tu bâtir après le bord
istria séjour détient le mur si cambria
que tes enfants en longue et l'on grâce
tiendront après pour le royal place du
fait de son emplacement supposée sur le
danube en pannonie on a fait parfois
coïncider si qu'ambri avec budapest la
capitale de la hongrie
mais tout comme la colonia trajane à le
long du rhin les ruines du vieux
budapest ne contiennent rien de probant
pour justifier une telle implantation
en ces temps anciens la pannonie était
tourmenté par les raids dévastateurs d
alain une peuplade descendus des
lointaines montagnes d'iran et d'arménie
l'empiré romain souffrait de ses
incursions mais comme les alains avaient
établi leur camp derrière un marais
impraticable ils restaient impunis
verlan 370 en désespoir de cause
l'empereur valentinien premier proclame
a alors à l'attention du monde
ceux qui sauront pénétrer ce marais et
en extraire cette méchante tribu je jure
de les affranchir d'impôts pendant dix
ans l'intrépide peuple francs répond
présent ils se ruent aussitôt sur les
alains et les expulse démarré comme
promis les francs sont exempts de tribus
à l' empire derrière les remparts de sic
en brie ils vivent de paisibles années
de prospérité
mais dix ans plus tard ils reçoivent la
visite du percepteur prix marius venus
réclamer le tribut annuel à l' empire
les francs refuse de s'en acquitter et
massacrent les serviteurs du fisc
pour venger cet affront valentinien
premier rassemble une immense armée
qu'il lance à l'assaut de sicogi
après d'âpres mêler ses légions prennent
le dessus et inflige une sévère défaite
au franc telle une nouvelle 3 les ruines
de la belle cité sonne le glas de sic en
brie désemparés les francs cherche une
réponse à leur malheur auprès des durs
le nouveau chef des francs s'appelle
marco mire tenue pour germanique le nom
de marco mire pourrait être celtic en
gaulois marcos veut dire cheval et
marroux ce grand ce qui ferait de marco
mire le grand cheval
une nuit marco me refais un songe
prémonitoire ou lui apparaît une bête
fantastique à trois têtes respectivement
de lyon daigle et de crapaud puis ces
trois têtes fusionnent en une seule tête
à la semblance d'un homme qui parle
chez les peuples païens a toujours
existé une caste de 2,20 plus ou moins
mystique en charge de guider les chefs à
faire le bon choix
[Musique]
intrigué par son rêve
marco mire consulte à lire une la
druidesse de la tribu le nom d'ali runes
contient la racine
runes qui signifie secret mystère en
langue sceptiques
or à lire une a précisément pour rôle de
dévoiler le mystérieux message envoyé
par les dieux selon elle chaque animal
symbolise un peuple
le lion représentent les francs l'aigle
les romains et le crapaud les gaulois
par cette vision les dieux de la patrie
enjoignent offrant de quitter sic en
brie et de migrer vers la gaule cette
errance légendaire des francs eu
beaucoup de succès auprès des historiens
en quête de nos origines
voici en 727 ce qu'enseignait scipion
dupleix conseiller et historiographe du
roi louis xiii
[Musique]
après certains charmes et enchantement
une prophétesse ou sybille ou plutôt une
sorcière nommé à lire une fait voir la
nuit en songe à marco mire un monstre à
trois têtes c'est à savoir de lyon de
crapauds et d'aigle chacune des nuits
par là et annonce à certaines
prédictions favorable et après toutes
trois se mirent en un corps de forme
humaine
leroy s'enquérant de la signification de
cette vision
à lire une l'exhortent à un final est
logé entre le lion et le crapaud entre
le rhin et la mer mais premier temps
sans doute que sa nation coup qu'elle ré
la terre du crapaud après plusieurs
sanglants combats et avec le temps
subjugueur est aussi la terre de l'aigle
et
ronsard met un chat huant à la place du
crapaud et rapporte ainsi la légende se
fait d'accord et en trois chefs divers
l'un d'eux choix aux yeux ardents et
père l'autre d'un aigle et l'autre la
figure d'un grand lyon la mâchoire ou
dur puis tous ces trois en à se
rassembler et c3 à face d'homme semblait
qui murmure on se voulait faire entendre
mais marco mire ne le pouvais comprendre
c'est qu'il fallait par le conseil des
dieux laissé six cordes et chercher un
autre lieu
les quatre personnages du songe de marco
mire compose d'un tetra morph dans le
christianisme le d'être amorphe qui
signifie en grec leucate forme est une
image symbolique des quatre évangélistes
mathieu à la physionomie d'un homme jean
celle d'un aigle marque d'un lyon et luc
d'un taureau un passage de l'apocalypse
décrit de façon très similaire aux
songes de marco mire le trône de dieu et
ceux qui l'entourent au milieu du trône
et autour de lui se tienne 4 vivent en
consteller dieu par bevand et par
derrière
le premier vivant et comme un lion le
deuxième vivant et comme un jeune
taureau le troisième vivant à comme un
visage d'homme le quatrième vivant et
comme un aigle en plein vol on retrouve
un peu la même vision chez le prophète
ezéchiel qui décrit ainsi les quatre
créatures du char de dieu
quant à la forme de leur fasse il avait
une face d'hommes et tous les quatre
avec une phase de lyon à droite et tous
les quatre avec une phase de taureaux à
gauche et tous les quatre avec une phase
daigle s'il existe quatre évangiles ni
plus ni moins on le doit à un père de
l'église le gaulois sainte irénée évêque
de lyon à la fin du iième siècle contre
les hérétiques
irene s'appuya sur une fois ternie t
sacré pour justifier qu'il ne pouvait y
avoir que quatre évangiles
par ailleurs il ne peut y avoir ni un
plus grand ni un plus petit nombre
d'évangile en effet puisqu'il existe
quatre régions du monde dans lequel nous
sommes et 80 principaux et puisque
d'autres par l'église répandu sur toute
la terre et qu'elle a pour colonne et
pour soutien l'évangile et l'esprit de
vie il est naturel que les quatre
colonnes qui souffrent de toutes parts
la corruptibilité et rende la vie aux
hommes d'où il appert que le verbe
artisans de l'univers qui siège sur les
chérubins et mattia toute chose
lorsqu'il s'est manifestée aux hommes
nous a donné un évangile à quoi deux
plateformes encore que maintenu par un
unique esprit le tetra morve de marco me
ressemble beaucoup au théâtre amorphe
chrétiens on y voit un homme un aigle un
lion
la différence se situe sur le quatrième
personnage
un taureau pour les chrétiens un crapaud
ou un chat huant pour les païens
obéissant à l'impérieuse voix des dieux
les francs abandonne donc la cité de sic
en brie se dirigeant vers le couchant il
migre à travers les forêts de germany et
s'installent le long du rhin sur les
bords du rhin les frontières de l'empiré
romain les tiennent à distance
à la fin du 4e siècle les guerriers
francs doivent se contenter de regarder
la gaule promise depuis l'autre rive du
fleuve
le premier historien de france lévesque
grégoire de tours son histoire des rois
francs écrit à la fin du 6e siècle est
la source principale pour tout ce qui
touche la gaule à cette époque
or grégoire ne dit rien de l'ascendance
troyenne des francs comme si cela ne les
concernait pas ce sont des sources
postérieur des 7e et 8e siècle qui font
le lien avec la cité dealer grégoire
reconnaît ignorer qu'elle fut le tout
premier roi des francs en revanche sur
la base d'informations sans doute orale
ils évoquent leur lieu d'origine et leur
exode depuis la pannonie
beaucoup rapporte en effet qu'il serait
venu de pannonie qu'il aurait d'abord
habité le long du rail puis ayant passé
le rat qu'ils auraient traversé la torah
j là chaque village et cités se plaça
sous des rois chevelu issue de la
première et si je puis dire de la plus
noble de leur famille
les sources antiques parle donc d'un
exode défend depuis trois et d'une
escale en panneaux et puis d'une
migration vers le nord de la gaule les
francs n'ayant pas encore de roy leurs
guides marco mire les exhorte à 100
choisir un il leur propose son propre
fils faramond le peuple accepte faramond
est lissée sur le pavois
comme il ne saurait y avoir deux
royaumes durable sont justice l'épée du
roi doit servir d'abord au bien commun
au sein de la tribu se dressait alors
trois lieux sacrés du nom de salle ram
botham évidament la officiers quatre
magistrats ces quatre singes inspirée
par l'expérience des années et dictent
les premiers statuts de la société et
rédige la fameuse loi salique les
francky terre alors si cambrai et
arrivèrent sur les bords du rhin dans
les régions germaniques
hilali terre là avec leur prince marco
mire fils de priam et sinon fils dans
tes nord après la mort de sinnoh il
tarde conseil afin de se choisir à voie
unique
à l'instar des autres peuples sur la vie
de marco mire il est lurçon fils
faramond est certes au dessus de ce roi
chevelu alors il commence à avoir des
lois qu'administrer les plus anciens
d'entre eux à savoir viso vaste et vise
au gast arts au gast ça le gast dans le
domaine sis outre-rhin de gotham salam
évidament
les plus anciens textes connus de la loi
salique remonte au 8e siècle de notre
ère ils ont été transcrits sous
charlemagne
mais leur contenu est beaucoup plus
ancien
il s'agit d'un code pénal qui présente
une société vieira refusé divisé en
trois ordres
les nobles l'ailette qui ont une
fonction militaire et les serres
l'âge légal de la responsabilité civile
est fixé à 12 ans les crimes et délits
font l'objet d'un classement précis par
exemple vol vol avec effraction ou vol
avec violence et beaucoup d'articles ont
créé aux infractions en milieu rural vol
de bétail dégâts sur les récoltes
atteinte aux animaux on observe un
certain souci du droit animal c'est
quelqu'un trouve dans son champ à
l'animal cheval ou bétail quelconque il
ne doit pas le frapper à outrance le
refus de comparaître au tribunal est
puni de 600 deniers ou 15 sous d'or
autant que le faux témoignage
les incivilités et les injures sont
réprimées
si quelqu'un a traite un autre de mer 2
il sera condamné à 120 de nier ou trois
sous d'or
le châtiment est parfois adaptés au
statut social du coupable selon qu'il
s'agit d'un cerf ou d'un noble on
apprend qu'un coup de verges équivaut à
une amende de cinq deniers
c'est un cerf est accusé de vol et que
pour un tel acte
un noble aurait dû s'acquitter de ses
sens de nier ou case dessous d'or le
cers sera étendue sera banc et recevra
100 la cour ce statut inégalitaire n'est
pas sans ambiguïté car la parole d'un
cerf n'a aucun poids face à celle d'un
hub s'y insèrent accuse son maître on ne
tiendra pas crédit la hiérarchisation de
la société influe sur l'union
matrimoniale la transgression de classe
se fait au détriment du supérieur
c'est un homme après en mariage la
servante d'un autre il tombera lui-même
en servitude avec elle
l'inceste est interdit ainsi que
l'avortement sait que qu'à tulle enfant
dans le ventre de la mère ou un
nouveau-né de moins de huit nuits et
n'ayant pas encore reçu de nom il sera
condamné à 4000 de nier ou sens où dort
l'enlèvement de femmes fait l'objet d'un
titre spécial qui rappelle les moeurs
païenne
[Musique]
le document juridique précise le nombre
de rallyes soeur et le lieu de
l'enlèvement
[Musique]
06/03 sommes ravis c'est une demoiselle
noble de sa maison ou de sa hutte
chacun d'entre eux sera condamné à 1000
de santonniers ou 30 sous d'or chose
curieuse cette technique de rapts
avaient peut-être coutume de s'effectuer
à l'aide de barques
si certains avaient des barques rapide
chacun d'entre eux sera condamnée à 120
de lier ou trois sous d'or
le viol est sévèrement châtiés même s'il
s'agit d'une femme de basse condition
sociale
s'y insèrent des bouches la servante de
quelqu'un
et qu elles en meurent le cers sera soit
castrés soit sera condamné à 240 de nier
ou 6 ou d'or est le maître du cercle
restituera la valeur de la servante
[Musique]
les coups et blessures sont punies d'une
amende proportionnelle au nombre de
coups assénés
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un frappe une personne à
coups de poing il sera condamné à 360 de
nier ou neuf sous d'or ou bien trois
sous d'or pour chaque coup
le meurtre tel l'empoisonnement est
condamnée par une peine financières
lourdes
si quelqu'un donne à boire des herbes
mortels il sera condamné à 8000 de nier
ou deux sens où dort quand le meurtre
est commis en réunion
c'est une circonstance aggravante
si quelqu'un à la tête d'un groupe attac
un noble chez lui et le tue il sera
condamné à 24 milles de nier ou six ans
où dort dans certains cas le recours à
la torture est légal notamment par
l'épreuve de la main plongez dans un
chaudron d'eau bouillante
quand le coupable de meurtre est
insolvable une procédure oblige les
membres de sa famille à lui venir en
aide
après quatre audiences
si personne n'a payé pour lui le prix du
meurtre
la peine capitale est alors prononcé et
c'est aucun des siens ne veut le
racheter en s'acquittant de la
composition judiciaire il sera mise à
mort la peine de mort semble avoir
surtout été par pendaison et il est
interdit de détacher le corps sans
autorisation judiciaire
si quelqu'un détache un cadavre du jb ou
de la potence sans décision du juge
il sera condamné à 1800 de nier ou 45
sous d'or un article surprenant touche
au culte de la tête coupée fichés sur un
pieu
cette pratique interdite par le clergé
était en vigueur au temps des druides et
la loi salique en conserve le fossile
macabre et fascinant si quelqu'un ose
enlever la tête d'un homme que son
ennemi avait placé sera mieux et ce sans
l'aval d'un juge ni de celui qu'il avait
posé là il sera condamné à six ans de
nier ou 15 sous d'or
la magie noire est interdite et son
usage condamné c'est quelqu'un jette un
sort à un autre où la terre dans un lieu
quelconque par un maléfice il sera
condamné à 2500 de nier ou 60 dessous
d'or et demi le cannibalisme fait
l'objet d'un article de loi
c'est une sorcière est reconnu coupable
d'avoir mangé de la chair humaine
elle sera condamnée à huit mille de nier
ou deux sens où dort
le respect dû au défunt est un sacré bon
condamne au bannissement du pays
celui qui aura violé une sépulture et
dépouillé un cadavre avec interdiction
faite à tous les habitants de le loger
ou de le nourrir
[Musique]
la loi salique remonte à une époque pré
chrétienne
on y décèle des traces de paganisme
par exemple voici le montant de l'amendé
pour le vol d'un port destinés à être
offerts aux divinités
si quelqu'un a volé un port castrés
sacré que l'on dit votifs et si le
propriétaire peut en privé par témoin la
destination au sacrifice
le voleur sera condamné à 700 deniers
qui font 17 soudeur et demi en plus de
la valeur de l'animal et de dommages
intérêts d'après la loi salique
l'héritage de la terre se fait
uniquement par la ligne et masculine
[Musique]
quant à la terre salik hop une part de
l'héritage ne reviendra à la femme c'est
tout sexe mâle que tout l'héritage la
terre reviendra durant la guerre de cent
ans
des légistes s'inspireront de cet
article patriarcal pour justifier que
l'héritage du trône de france ne se
transmet que par le lignage masculin
rejetant ainsi les prétentions anglaise
[Musique]
le comptage du temps ne se fait pas en
jours mes ennuis
selon l'ancienne coutume des druides le
centre géographique du rayonne la loi
salique est en gaule entre la loire et
la forêt charbonnières un seul article
donne une indication spatiale il
concerne le délai légal pour le
traitement d'une affaire
si celui chez qui l'objet volé a été
saisi 2 meur au delà de la loire ou de
la forêt charbonnière on prolonge le
délai légal à 80 nuit
la juridiction de la loi salique s'étend
donc en priorité à une partie de la
gaule ce qui est en contradiction avec
le règne de phares à mon sens est alors
siéger outre-rhin
d'où souvent l'attribution de la loi
salique à clovis dont le royaume à ses
débuts se situera en gaule du nord
quelques rares articles font référence
au franc et aux romains
par exemple dans le cas d'un vol voici
le montant des amendes
selon l'origine du voleur ou de sa
victime c'est un roman des trous safran
il sera condamné à 2500 de nier ou 72
heures et demie c'est affreux
des troncs sarona il sera condamné à
1202 liés ou 30 soudards un franc vaut
donc pénalement deux fois plus qu'un
romain mais ces articles ont quelque
chose de sûre ajouté car l'essentiel du
code pénal est ailleurs la loi salique
brille surtout par son anonymat
à l'origine elle ne mentionne aucun roi
précis ni aucune ville est à peine les
francs et les romains comme si elle
était le fruit juridique de quelqu'un
d'autre
l'absence de repères concrets confère à
cette constitution antique un parfum
autochtones et intemporelle la loi
salique apparaît donc comme un code
pénal payen surgi du fond des âges en
gaule du nord à la fin de l'empiré
romain
on peut se demander s'il ne s'agit pas
du code pénal des anciens druide
conservé par les populations de la gaule
est adapté aux réalités politiques du
haut moyen-âge
tel serait l'oeuvre grandiose du
légendaire faramond leroy juristes
en résumé faramineux et ses quatre sages
se réunissent dans trois cités est
promue elle de la loi salique ensuite
les fronts traverseront le rhin pour
aller s'installer en hall
qu'en est-il de l'authenticité de ce
récit chez les peuples de cultures indo
européenne il est fréquent que des
structures identiques et prévalu à la
formation légendaire du pays
un détour par la mythologie comparer
permettra de mieux jauger les événements
du règne de faramond en irlande les
anciens dieux païens formaient la tribu
de dana
selon la mémoire ethnique cette tribu de
heroes aurait d'abord vécu dans de
mystérieuses îles au nord du monde là
dans les plaines sauvages
elle aurait appris de la bouche de 4
druides les arts magiques ses droïdes
siéger dans quatre cités
[Musique]
puis une fois cet enseignement à qui la
tribu de dana aurait traversé la mer et
gagner l'irlande les similitudes entre
les deux légendes sont frappantes pour
la tribu des francs comme pour la tribu
de dana on trouve les correspondances
suivante
dans un lointain passé la tribu vivait
sur une terre au delà d'une étendue
d'eau en germanie au delà du rhin ou
dans les îles au nord du monde là quatre
sages qui officiait dans trois ou quatre
villes ont fondé le code sacré la loi
salique où la magie druidique
le code sacré fondé la tribu traversera
l'eau et ira faire souche dans sa
nouvelle patrie la france ou l'irlande
au vu des coïncidences précise entre les
deux pays celtiques
il semble probable qu'un même logiciel
culturel est servi de moules fondateur
le récit des origines est quasi
identique en france et en irlande
on se souvient des informations données
sur les origines des celtes par
l'historien grec team à gênes au 1er
siècle avant notre ère et reprise par
ammien marcellin elle inquiète ici tout
leur sens les druides mentionne de
source sûre une partie du peuple est
indigène mais que l'autre au flux edi le
lointaine et de migration d'outre-rhin
chassés de leurs foyers par l'abondance
des guerres et par les débordements de
la mer
par transfert épique les origines des
celtes enseignée par les droid sont
devenus les origines des francs
[Musique]
farah mme dont on situe le début de
règne autour de 420 et le premier roi de
la monarchie française
sous louis xiii on enseignait de
faramond voilà comment faramond ayant
été le premier roi s'ouvre à et absolue
de toutes les nations du non français
est à bon droit tenue pour le chef et
co-fondateur de la monarchie française
encore qu'il n'ait pas mis le pied en
gaule où elle a été depuis établi ce qui
pourrait être cause que grégoire évêque
de tours le plus exact et fidèle de nos
anciens historiens n'en a pas fait
mention
malgré son aura antique deux fondateurs
de la royauté aucun fils de la ligne et
mérovingienne ne portera jamais le nom
de farrah mais cette absence révélatrice
témoigne de l'épaisse brume de
mythologie qui enveloppe le premier roi
le nom de faramond est peut être liée au
rôle qu'il remplit en langue
indo-européenne la racine bregman des il
prête de la vienne les noms du brahmanes
en inde et du flamine à rome qui
exercent tous deux la fonction de prêtre
or en tant que faiseur de loi faramond
rempli lui aussi l'office d'un roi
prêtre
[Musique]
si faramond n'aurait jamais mis le pied
en gaule de son vivant il n'en est pas
de même après sa mort selon la mémoire
locale
le tombeau de faramond serait située
dans les vosges à framont dont le nom
signifierait le monde et francs
c'est à clodion fils de faramond que va
revenir l'honneur de s'installer en
gaule avec son peuple
les roi des francs commence alors à se
distinguer par le port de longs cheveux
c'est à cette époque que l'on commença
d'avoir des rois chevelu la coutume
antique darbo rire une longue chevelure
en guise de noblesse perdurera si bien
que 1300 ans après claudio louis xiv
sera encore ainsi représenté jadis ont
donné le nom de gaule chevelue à
l'espace situé entre le rhin et les
pyrénées avec ces trois provinces la
belgique au nord la celtique au centre
et l'aquitaine au sud ouest
il est troublant que ce soit précisément
en entrant en gaule chevelue que les
francs auront à coeur d'avoir des rois
chevelu
l'arverne sidoine apollinaire qui a
rencontré des francs fourni dans ses
poèmes quelques détails sur leur aspect
physique le rutilante chevelure tirée du
sommet du crâne le retourne sur le front
mise à nu leurs nuques reluit de leurs
yeux gris brille un regard clair
l'envisagent est en rasé de près il se
liste à la place de la barbe
une fine moustache avec le père grégoire
de tours ne dit rien de faramond dont il
n'a pas entendu parler ou qu'il ne
considérait pas comme un roi franc mais
il a eu vent d'un certain roi clodion
hook logions selon sa plume le domaine
de ce roi franc aurait été située en
thuringe il habitait le château de 10
par an rapportent qu'il y avait alors un
roi des francs valeureuse est très connu
dans sa nation claudio qui siégeait au
château de disparus sur le territoire
des tur à gien
où est disparu le nom fait penser à
duisbourg gh en allemagne ou à duisbourg
en belgique mais l'archéologie restant
muette
il est possible que le nom soit mythique
est d'origine gauloise
selon les sources dix parcs s'est créé
aussi 10 bargues le premier terme 10 est
peut-être la contraction de devo ce qui
signifie divin quant au second il peut
s'agir de parcus le chêne ou de bergot
le monde le château de claudio aurait
porté le nom du divin chaîne ou du divin
monde il est notoire que chez les
peuples indo européen
l'arbre où la colline soit souvent
divinisé est en rapport avec les dieux
céleste
dès l'aube de son règne clodion se
présente comme un chef de guerre ce qui
contraste avec son prédécesseur le roi
juriste farah
[Musique]
claudio convoitent les épaisses forêts
du nord de la gauche
[Musique]
alors le roi des francs il dissémine des
espions des pêches des troupes les verts
et égrène ses guerriers aux points
névralgiques
puis franchissant le rhin avec son arme
et ils font sur l' empire et triomphe
des légionnaires volant
le conquérant chevelu s'empare ainsi de
la ville de cambrai et des terres
jusqu'aux rives de la somme
claudio en wyatt des espions du château
turin chien le disparu vers la ville de
cambrai ensuite avec une grande armée et
traversant le rhin massacre a beaucoup
de rona et les mythes en fuite et
l'envoyer la forêt charbonnières et
s'empara de tourner de la ce en allant à
cambrai il est résident à quelques temps
tu mens les romains qu'ils y trouvaient
puis il conquit les terres jusqu'à la
somme l'empiré romain ne pouvait rester
sans réagir
vers 4 131 le général romain et us
l'once une violente offensive
et si l'on suit la chronique la mêlée
fut assez original dans l'artois près du
village d'elena les fronts organisé une
fête entre vertes collines et calme
rivière on y célèbre un mariage
bucolique
[Musique]
aux dires de sidoine apollinaire
l'ambiance est joyeuse et les couples
toute en blondeur s'ébattent tendance
nordiques seront collées une proche de
la rive résonnait la noce barbare et
dansante à la manière des sites ont
marié la jeune fiancée à un époux aussi
blanc qu'elle le laisser-aller la
douceur de vivre la musique la boisson
clodion était à mille lieues d'imaginer
qui allait s'inviter à la
fin stratège et youth a prévu
d'accueillir l'ennemi à l'improviste à
son signal les soldats romains se ruent
sur les réjouissances prise au dépourvu
les danses nordique s'éparpillent dans
nos cheveux les clodion et vaincus et us
triomphe
ce gros chahut n'aura toutefois aucune
conséquence fâcheuse
car le chef militaire de l'empiré
d'occident connaîtront bien la faiblesse
de ses effectifs
il sait aussi que les peuples
germaniques ne demande qu à s'assimiler
aux populations locales
alors aytus modère sa victoire avec
claudio il scelle une paie de compromis
les français obtiennent le droit de
s'établir au nord de la gaule
en contrepartie ils auront à charge d'en
garder la frontière c'est ce royaume de
tournai octroyé par l'enpi raclot dieu
qui est à la source du domaine familial
de clovis
[Musique]
un été sur les rivages de la mer
un couple vient passer du bon temps
c'est le roi clodion accompagné de son
épouse
sous un soleil au zénith
la dame s'enfonce dans les flots pour y
nager c'est alors que surgit un monstre
marin
le kino tort il agrippe la jeune femme
et l'emmène sous les plis ou le des
vagues de sept
écumant étreinte va naître un garçon
hardy mérovée l'ancêtre éponyme de la
lignée mérovingienne la chronique de
frais des guerres sont fait l'écho cette
génération était entouré de coutume
païenne
on raconte que pendant l'été à midi
claude y ont séjourné sur le bord de la
mer avec son épouse tandis que celle-ci
s'avançait dans la mer pour s'y baigner
elle fut convoité par une bête de
neptune semblable au kino tort
après que le tt fécondée par cette bête
ou par son mari elle enfante a un fils
nommé mérovée duquel des rafles en
furent ensuite appelé mérovingiens par
sa naissance
ambigu mire v présente une rupture
génétique avec ses prédécesseurs et il
est lié à l'élément marin en tant que
premier roi franc n'est en gaule
il est si l'on peut dire gaulois par
droit du sol
mme hervé devient roi vert 448 en
échange de son autorité reconnue par l'
empire
il doit servir l'armée romaine en lui
fournissant un contingent de soldats
or les temps sont durs
l'empiré romain affaibli par des
querelles politiques et par un déclin
démographique ne parvient plus à
maintenir sa frontière étanche en 451 le
limes crack les légions du rhin
s'effondre le chef des envahisseurs et
le roi des huns attila on le surnomme le
fléau de dieu
à la tête d'une vaste coalition de
barbares la tribu des uns se jettent à
l'assaut de la gaule
proche de la frontière
la région de tongs et ravagé
devant le désastre des armes sincères va
l'évêque du diocèse cherche dans la
prière et le jeûne
trois jours durant l'ultime secours de
dieu c'est sous la forme d'un rêve
prémonitoire qu'il reçoit une réponse
équivoque
l'apôtre pierre lui apparaît et lui
annonce que tondre sera anéanti pour ses
péchés
avant d'ajouter à l'adresse du prélat
mais toi marche jusqu'au port fluvial
duguay sur la meuse où tu pourras tu
n'iras tous les saints tes frères dans
le ciel car le guay est hors d'atteinte
et paisible mais tour sera écrasée brisé
vide est et restera active jusqu'à la
fin des temps au cours de leurs razia
les uns seraient parvenus à enlever à
mérovée son épouse et son jeune fils
childéric ceux-ci ne doivent leur salut
qu'à l'intervention d'un fidèle
lieutenant guy ne m'en appelé aussi
vieux mad qui les aident à s'échapper
le très fidèle flavio mad avaient été
des fils d'éric à s'enfuir celui ci
ayant été emmenés captifs avec sa mère
par les uns
fidèle au pacte qui les lie à la
fédération roumaine me relever et c'est
france se joignent aux gaulois et aux
wisigoths la coalition de l' empire est
emmenée par le général en chef de
l'occident aytus les troupes d'attila
s'enfonce dans le nord de la gaule mais
connaissent plusieurs échecs
[Musique]
sainte-geneviève les repousses de paris
saint-aignan les refoule d'orléans et
saint loup les rejette de 3,7 aux champs
catalauniques en champagne que l'ultime
bataille va se dérouler comme
l'expliquent le chroniqueur jordan s on
se rencontre ainsi au sens catalauniques
qu'on nomme aussi mauriac cette partie
de la terre devient donc la reine où
s'affrontent d'innombrables peuple
désarmé en vienne thomas très valeureuse
l'une et l'autre
défi titanesque
les francs et apportent leur
contribution notamment au commencement
des hostilités en fait au cours de cette
guerre fameuse limite aux prises les
plus valeureuses nation on rapporte
qu'il y eût 165 mille morts dans les
deux camps
sans compter quinze mille dépit des
francs qui avant la mêlée générale
s'étaient affrontés de nuit et s'était
infligé des blessures mutuelles puisque
les francs combattez pour les romains et
les epide pour les 1 au terme de la
vaste mais les l'occident celle de
germano roumains prend le dessus et
chasse au delà du rhin la nasa fera
cette victoire des champs catalauniques
en 451 se situe qu'au niveau des ciels
elle est le dernier triomphe de l'empiré
romain d'occident est le premier grand
fait d'armes des francs au service de la
civilisation européenne
ni vers 440 childéric succède à son père
mérovée en 457
il est le quatrième roi depuis faraman
là
s'il faut en croire les chroniques de
l'époque childéric a la particularité
d'être très concupiscent dès l'aube de
son règne il s'autorise séduire les
filles du pays et les dévergonde selon
sa fantaisie
les bons pères de famille s'en émeuvent
exaltée par le parfum de scandale
les foules se soulève contre les
mauvaises moebs bientôt une révolution
enfle et l'ont expulsée du trône seront
à esclave de sa sensualité
comme le roi childéric fils de mérovée
était particulièrement voluptueux il se
mit à débaucher et à prostituées les
filles des fera alors saisi d'une grande
colère ceux ci s'en indignent air et
voulurent l'abattre et le chasser du
royaume mais dans cette tempête
politique childéric n'est pas seul
il sait pouvoir compter sur son fidèle
ami guinamant guinamant partagea soudeur
en deux il ordonne une moitié à celle
d'éric et lui dit va te cacher loin
d'ici quand je t'enverrai ma moitié de
pièces c'est que tu pourra revenir en
toute sécurité
influent tant l'expérience de son
complice childéric part aussitôt en exil
il se rend chez le roi bazin de thuringe
mais les meubles fugitif
s'il a abandonné sa patrie n'a pas
abandonné ses penchants plus échevelée
que chevelu le charmeur séduit bientôt
bazine la jeune épouse de son hôte bazin
pendant ce temps là semble aider frank
porte sur le trône d'un prince gallo
romain nommé gillon
par la flatterie l'habile dignement
parvient à s'en faire le conseiller
ligne mans qui était grand ami au roi
childéric effet sage et plein de grandes
manifs temps fait en peu de temps qu'il
se lia intimement aura gillot lequel ne
faisait rien sans son conseil
car ils le croyaient sont plus loyal
amis
guînes mans est en réalité un espion ce
qu'il veut c'est rendre gillon si
impopulaire que les francs réclameront
le retour de childéric alors il lui
conseille de persécuter les francs par
la pression fiscale
mais les francs loin de s'insurger
contre de tels excès d'impôts préfère se
résigner à la ruine temps ils se
souviennent des caresses hardy de
childéric sur leur fille les francs
acceptèrent en se disant pour nous il
vaut mieux nous a quittés d'attributs de
3 sous que de mener une vie des plus
pénibles avec celle d'eric
contrarié dans ses projets guînes mans
pousse gillon à employer la force et lui
soumet des vauriens comme de dangereux
séditieux que l'autre ordonne de faire
exécuter
poursuivant son double jeu dignement
s'entretient en secret avec les francs
faisant allusion à leur exil forcé de
sic en brie à cause des romains il
stimule les francs contre le gouverneur
gillon et retourne l'opinion en faveur
de childéric il dit au franc pourquoi ne
vous souvenez vous pas comment les
oppresseurs romain en chasse et votre
peuple et vous ont expulsé de votre pays
en vérité c'est vous qui avait chassé
votre roi valeureuse et sage et qui
avait élevé au dessus de vous ce soldats
de l'empereur orgueilleuse et suffisant
ce n'est pas une bonne résolution que
vous avez prises mais une très mauvaise
les francs répondiez à guignes mans
c'est qu'il se montre et téméraire avec
nous mais nous nous repentons d'avoir
fait cela notre roi puis sur nous mérite
et qu'il revienne qu'il règne sur nous
dans la paix alors la meilleure voyait a
suggéré que sa partie dessous qu'ils
avaient autrefois partagé en lui disant
revient au royaume des francs
parce que tout a été pacifié
rentré en possession de l'autre moitié
de pièces childéric reprend le chemin de
son pays
mais il ne rentre pas seul
[Musique]
l'aven bazine abandonnant son époux
bazin décide de convoyer avec son
irrésistible avant
ah ah
à
les motivations de la femme infidèle ne
manque pas de piquant
aussi basile délaissant son époux
accompagna childéric par curiosité
alors que celui-ci l'interrogé sur ce
qu'elle cherchait est la raison pour
laquelle elle venait avec lui depuis à
sylvain tapis on rapporte qu elle lui
répondre je sais la valeur est à botter
combien tu es valeureux et sage
je suis venu habiter avec toi mais si
j'avais eu connaissance n'a plus
valeureux que toi au delà des mers c'est
lui que j'aurais convoité et épouse est
au comble de la joie
s'il d'eric l'a pris pour épouse de
cette union
l enfant a un fils qu'à la plaque lovis
ce fut le plus grand roi des francs et
un combattant très courageux face à
l'instable chevalier la dame mystérieuse
diffuse comme un halo dhombres childéric
et bazine préfigure les couples
romanesque de la littérature médiévale
tel pépin le bref hébertot grands pieds
raymond et la fée mélusine ou encore
tristan et iseult
[Musique]
toujours l'homme n'est que simple mortel
mais la femme rayonne d'une aura de
saintes ou de fait dans les mythes
traditionnel ce personnage féminin très
typé à l'instar de la déesse eyrieux qui
symbolise l'irlande est l'incarnation de
la souveraineté
or c'est précisément la souveraineté de
son royaume que reconquiert childéric
maintenant qu'ils ramènent bazine avec
lui
la future mère de clovis possède le don
de voyance lors de leur nuit de noce
voulons mettre son talent au service de
son nouvel époux la chaste fiancée di
achille d'eric cette nuit nous nous
abstiendrons de rapports charnels
lève-toi du lit va dans la cour du
palais et rapporte à ces reventes ce que
tu y aura vu trois fois de suite la
scène se répète childéric se lève va
voir dans la course qu'il s'y passe puis
le rapport à son et pose la première
fois le roi des francs voit dans la cour
du palais un lion et les licornes et un
léopard
la deuxième fois il voit des ours et des
loups
[Musique]
la troisième fois il voit des chiens et
de petites bêtes se chamailler les uns
les autres
ce rituel terminé les deux époux sendin
dans l'abstinence
au matin bazine donne la clé de la
triple apparitions nocturnes elle dit à
childéric ce que tu as vu de tes yeux au
mont m c'est la vérité à venir
de nous naîtra un fils qui aura la force
du lion et les fils de celui ci auront
la force des léopards et des licornes
puis ceux-ci engendreront des ours et
des loups voraces enfin les chiens des
petites bêtes c'est la descendance
finale et les peuples qui sans crainte
pour les princes se déchirent sur une
semaine d'après la tradition bazine
aurait ainsi annoncé la venue prochaine
du grand clovis le lion et de ses quatre
fils thierry clodomir childebert et flo
terre les léopards et les licornes tous
noble de caractère puis viendront les
petits fils les ours et les loups au
tempérament brutales telles clotaire 2
et sa génération
enfin paraîtront les derniers
mérovingiens les chiens et petites bêtes
rois fainéants dont la faible
personnalité sera cause de détérioration
pour tout le pays
[Musique]
c'est la seconde fois qu'une voyante
intervient auprès d'un chef d'état ah si
quand brille en effet à lire une avait
interprété le songe de marco mire
mais il ya une différence
c'est à l'initiative des dieux que mark
o'meara avait reçu un songe
[Musique]
à lire une druidesse mystique demeure
comme hors du temps à zine hrw et est
plus terre à terre apporte la garantie
du foyer recouvrait
c'est à bar-le-duc dans la meuse que
childéric rejoint son fidèle compagnon
guinamant en récompense de la fête
donnée par les habitants à son retour
d'exil le roi les exempte d'impôts quand
il fait un eichmann et laure donnât
guînes manceau loyal amis de venir vite
à sa rencontre
celui ci accompagné de nombreux barreaux
la droite un château appelé barre puis
il commanda aux bourgeois et au peuple
de la ville de recevoir honorablement le
roi leur seigneur ce qu'ils firent
volontiers il leur sueur avec grand joie
et l'eau n'aura autant que possible le
roi leur en sucre est monté et pour
l'honneur qu'il y a de fait selon sa vie
des rallyes t il les exhorte à du tribut
que la vie lui donner tous les ans
les années childéric sont sous les
auspices des femmes des foulées de
l'argent surtout c'est sous son règne et
sous son règne seulement que le peuple
acquiert une existence propre
au point de s'affirmer comme forces
nationales roi de la ruse et de la
brigue childéric ne forment avec son
double dignement qu une même et unique
pièce sur l'échiquier politique
vulnérables à l'opinion publique ce
n'est que quand les sondages lui sont
favorables qu'il peut revenir en goal
com roi chine derrick est le seul roi
qui a dû se faire lui-même roi et grâce
au soutien populaire
il est le roi du tiers état loin d'être
un ingrat il sait à qui il doit tout son
retour s'accompagne d'une baisse
d'impôts immédiates donc
d'enrichissement populaire si la vie de
childéric telle qu'elle nous est
rapportée est digne d'un roman
ce roi n'en est pas moins curieusement
le plus historique de tous car il existe
des traces archéologiques de son
existence
le gouverneur gallo-romain gillon ayant
été chassé du trône childéric recouvre
vers 465 son royaume de tournai qui
s'étend sur la pointe nord de la gaule
en 466 ils engendrent de base in un fils
le célèbre clovis childéric gouverne la
nation des francs pendant de nombreuses
années il assiste à la silencieuse
disparition de l'empiré romain
d'occident en 476 et meurt en 480 le
peuple francs lui organise alors des
funérailles grandioses ont bâti un
tumulus à tournai où l'on dépose le
sarcophage
dans le tombeau auprès du monarque en
place salle ans et sa francisque pour
veiller sur le long sommeil du roi on la
compagne d'une effigie du divina yole de
la famille le kino tort un manteau
pourpre symbole des généraux romains
habille le prince ce manteau est cousu
d'une trentaine d'abeilles d'or est
fermé par une fibule à son doigt se
trouve une chevalière gravée d'un visage
aux cheveux longs avec l'inscription
latine qu'il dit ricky ray guise roi
shield eric lejoyeux payen childéric
s'envolent ainsi le coeur léger vers les
cieux ethnique rejoindre les walkyries
franck l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là les
siècles passent on oublie le tumulus on
oublie childéric le kino tort et les
abeilles d'or le 27 mai 753 lors de
travaux de terrassement la pioche d'un
ouvrier heures un coin renfoncer du sol
et tombe par hasard sur une cavité
rempli de trésors antiques c'est la
tombe de childéric
[Musique]
lors des fouilles bijoux et mobiliers
sont extraits est offert en 755 au jeune
roi louis xiv lointain descendant du
fils de mme hervé la résurrection de
childéric ne sera pas sans conséquence à
l'autre du 19e siècle
napoléon 1er cherche pour ses armoiries
zain période un symbole d'enracinement
nationale il ne trouve dans les abeilles
d'or du manteau pourpre du père de
clovis
[Musique]
les cinq premiers chefs des front à
savoir marko mire faramond claudio
merveille et childéric sont-ils
d'historique
ou bien les récits de leur vie sont ils
au moins en partie
imprégné d'anciens croyances païennes il
se trouve que ces cinq prince s'insère
parfaitement dans l'organigramme des
trois fonctions indo européennes dont
l'ossature théogonie qui remonte à
plusieurs millénaires avant notre ère
la symbolique des 3 fonctions a été
découverte et étudié au 20e siècle par
le professeur georges dumézil à travers
de volumineuse étude
il reste à ce jour le plus grand savant
dans ce domaine
[Musique]
les trois fonctions sont les suivantes
selon l'ordre hiérarchique
la première fonction concerne la
souveraineté sacré et juridique
la deuxième fonction recouvre la force
guerrière
la troisième fonction plus disparates
comprend tout ce qui a trait à la
production et aux grands noms fertilité
femmes argent foule nerfs et c'est cette
tripartition dates et des temps
préhistoriques sert de modèle à la
société médiévale la france des rois
s'organise
en effet selon trois ordres le clergé la
noblesse et le tiers état
[Musique]
de l'harmonie entre prêtres chevalier et
paysans dépend l'equilibre de tout le
pays autour de l'an mil lemoine à
d'albert ont de l'eau sont fait l'écho
auprès du roi robert le pieux la maison
du seigneur que l'on dit une est en fait
très peu les un prix ou combattent et
les autres travaillent ces trois classes
sont unis et ne supporte pas d'être
séparées chacune est établie par
l'office des deux autres par leurs
oeuvres
elle se soulagent l'une l'autre cette
union simple et donc trip ainsi prévoit
la loi
ainsi le monde repose en paix
cette organisation tripartite perdurera
jusqu'à la révolution de 1789 et même au
delà puisque les trois pouvoirs de
l'état à savoir le juridique l'exécutif
et le législatif
on sont directement inspirés dans les
récits anciens teinté de mythologie
païenne les trois fonctions
transparaissent de façon plus subtile
ce sont souvent des personnages tels des
dieux ou des rois qui à travers leurs
actes respectifs se rattache tantôt à la
souveraineté
tantôt à la guerre tantôt à la fertilité
quelques exemples en scandinavie en inde
et à rome suffiront à montrer comment
les choses se présentent
oh
dans la mythologie scandinave la
fonction sacrée est patronné par deux
dieux le magicien odin et le légaliste
tille la fonction guerrière et dirigé
par le belliqueux thor odin tir et or
sont de la tribu divine des a's
à la troisième fonction on trouve une
autre tribu les vannes qui domine tout
ce qui a trait à la prospérité
les personnages emblématiques en sont le
vieux njord patron de la mère et ses
enfants frais et freya qui sont à la
fois frères et soeurs et marié
en inde chez les à rien on observe un
organigramme identiques quant à la
hiérarchie des dieux la fonction sacrée
et patronnée par le magicien varona et
le légaliste mithra
la fonction guerrière par le combattant
indra varuna mithra et indra sont de la
famille des hadiths ya donc deux souches
noble à la troisième fonction on trouve
une autre famille léna attias composé de
jumeaux les âges vinh associé à la
déesse suc ania
[Musique]
à rome le décor est différent la
hiérarchie théorique met en scène nue
des dieux mais des rois successifs la
fonction sacrée se reconnaît dans le
premier roi romulus qui est magicien et
dans le deuxième roi
numa qui établit les lois
leroy suivant tullus hostile us est un
insatiable guerrier à la troisième
fonction on trouve leroy suivant en cus
martius il doit son trône au soutien
populaire
en fondant le port dostie il donne à
rome l'extension vers la mer et favorise
la prospérité la séparation génétique
entre les deux premières fonctions et la
troisième se situe ici non pas entre les
personnages mais à la fondation de la
cité avec les deux tribus originel les
romains et les sapins
ainsi que ce soit sous la forme d'une
théogonie comme en scandinavie en inde
ou d'une succession de roy comme à rome
des rôles précisé identiques ont été
assignés aux personnages fondateur chez
tous les peuples indo européen germain à
rien romain mais aussi celte grec
iranien slave et d'autres encore les
récits d origine concorde la structure
des trois fonctions y est toujours
présente et mis en évidence qu'en est il
de la série des cinq chefs francs
qu'elle si mme préval au cours de leurs
règnes successifs d'abord marco mirent à
la cité de sic en brie il fait un songe
ou lui apparaît le tetra morph avec ces
trois têtes animales et sa tête humaine
c'est ainsi que les dieux lui intime
l'ordre d'émigrer vers les rivages du
rhin étant inspirée par le ciel mark
o'meara paraît comme un souverain sacré
[Applaudissements]
son fils faramond une fois proclamé roi
établi avec quatre sages la loi salique
faramond et le souverain juridique
son fils le roi claudio envahi par les
armes une petite portion tout au nord de
la gaule pour y implanter le foyer
ethnique
claudio et le roi guerrier à ce moment
la lignée royale connaît une coupure
génétique due à l'intervention du kiné
automne
[Musique]
c'est dans la mer que le roi mme hervé
et conçu par les pousses de claudio et
le kino tort étant le fondateur de la
dynastie dit mérovingienne m'hervé jouit
d'une prérogative biologique
enfin son fils childéric par la faveur
populaire conquérir le royaume et par
son charme conquiert la reine bazine
dont ils engendrent le grand clovis
childéric et le roi séducteur
on est là typiquement de vente une
structure trifonctionnel
la fonction sacrée est occupée par marco
mines le guide inspiré du ciel et
faramond le faiseur de loi la fonction
guerrière par le batailleur clodion la
fonction productive fruit du kilo d'or
est occupée par mme hervé qui donne son
patronyme à la ligne par childéric le
séducteur et par la reine basile
il existe une correspondance évidente
entre les organigrammes respectives des
premiers rois francs des dieux
scandinaves des dieux à rien et des
premiers roi de rome en fonction un sont
liées au sacré marco me baudin varuna et
romulus et sont liées au droit
fava mon tir mitra et numa
en fonction deux sont liés à la guerre
clodion tort indra es tu l'usso stylus
là intervient une séparation génétique
entre les chefs antérieure au kino tort
et les descendants du kino tort entre la
tribu des zaz et celle des vannes entre
la famille des aditya et celle des nazes
attira et entre les romains et les
sabots
[Musique]
en fonction 3 liée à la fertilité à la
femme est souvent à l'espace marin on
trouve m'hervé childéric et basile njord
frais effrayant les jumeaux aschwin les
sucs indien
et en plus mars us
en france le récit des cinq premiers
chefs compose donc une taie ogms
historiciser
au delà de l'historicité possible de tel
ou tel roi la mémoire ethnique fait
appel à des souvenirs culturelle bien
plus lointain
telle la structure trifonctionnel hérité
des temps 1 2 européen
[Musique]
la légende troyenne de la france est née
lorsqu'on a projeté d'anciens mythe
celtic sur des rois francs ces rois
francs réels ou supposés sont devenus
les héros du renouveau national de la
gaule mais il se constitua alors un
doublé tandis que le parchemin évoque
l'origine troyenne des francs la mémoire
orale et populaire qui ne s'est pas
interrompue pour autant continue de
raconter l'origine troyenne des gaulois
les générations passent on on se rend
compte de la chose et l'on tente d'y
remédier vers 12 150 le roi saint louis
commando moines primat de saint denis
une chronique en français qui
raconterait les événements importants
survenus sous les rois mérovingiens
carolingien et capétiens ainsi est née
louvre âge les grandes chronique de
france qui sera continué au siècle
suivant
fidèles à la tradition les grandes
chronique de france fait commencer
l'histoire de notre pays à la chute de
troie suivent l'échappée de france ion
et la fondation de sic en brie
mais on y ajoute alors un curieux
paragraphe
[Musique]
juste après la fondation de sic en brie
une partie des troyens 23000 exactement
auraient migré vers l'ouest
[Musique]
leur chef s'appelait ibor le nom du bord
et certainement celtique
on y décèle la racine et bureau ce qui
est le nom de l'ihf cet arbre qui peut
vivre plus de mille ans était un symbole
de longévité et dean mortalité il existe
d'ailleurs représenté sur un menhir un
dieu druidique du nom d'yves eric ce qui
signifie le roi de leaf c'est peut-être
ce dieu druidique que la mémoire
médiévale a conservé sous le nom du chef
légendaire i bord
[Musique]
libor et une partie des six combres à
rift en gaule
la contrée est en vierge d'habitants ces
premiers venus tombe sous le charme des
lieux
séduit par la pureté de l'horizon et le
souffle des paysages
ici comme au premier matin du monde la
nature enfants tous les climats et vibre
sous la pétillante présence des dieux
ces premiers si cambre font souche
s'enracine dans ce sol sacré et
deviennent les gaulois en 895 avant
notre ère sur les rivages de la scène le
prince igor fait bâtir la cité de lutèce
qui deviendra plus tard paris
l'archéologie confirme en partie la
chronique cette date 2 - 895 coïncide en
effet avec les premières migrations
celtique de l'âge du fer ancien en ce
temps là les gaulois vives sont rois
dans la paix et la liberté
ce qui ne les empêche pas sur le tard de
participer à l' empire romain toute
cette chance ne demeura pas dans ce pays
mais hors des partis qu'une compagne
d'un 3000 furent par nous
entre eux certains duc kiên ou ebook
ils laissèrent d'allemagne germany pour
quérir nouvel habitat angola rivère le
pays et la terre leur plume août et
mouthe leur semble la charmante à
demeurer sur le fleuve de seine avis car
qui fondèrent klein cité qu'ils
nommèrent lutèce qui aurait appelé paris
895 en avant la carnation de notre
seigneur l'a invitèrent 1270 ans depuis
que leurs ancêtres furent partie de six
camps en ce temps vivait simplement peu
savaient de l' usage d'armes autant de
l'or n'avait aucun roi en france
chacun faisait ce que bon lui semblait
mais toutefois était-il sujet des
romains et faisait chaque année nouveau
conseilleurs de l'argent aussi pour le
peuple gouverner ainsi comme ceux de
roms c'est alors que vers 375 de notre
ère surviennent les francs
les gaulois font bon accueil au franc
car ils sont deux mêmes origines
gauloises et france ont tous deux issus
de sic en brie cette bienvenue sonnent
comme des retrouvailles après une longue
séparation
selon les grandes chronique de france le
premier chef des francs à entrer en
gaule est marco mire
[Musique]
à
l' empire romain s'effondrant peu à peu
marco me renseigne la politique aux
gaulois ils les instruits au maniement
des armes et couvre le pays de
puissantes citadelle ses châteaux forts
ont pour but de protéger le peuple
contre les brigands et les barbares fort
de son expérience
marco mirettes alors promu par les
gaulois au rang de gouverneur de la
gauche
[Musique]
désormais francs et gaulois forment une
seule et même nation
[Musique]
en ce temps entre un marco mirent en
france se marre comme here avait été
fait sur aprilia d'autriche qui était
descendue de la lignée du grand roi
priam de 3 ceux de gaulle leur sur moult
honorablement et toute sa jambe
et pour ceux qui leur enseigne à l'usagé
des armes et qu'il fit clore les cités
et les châteaux de muraille contre les
assauts des larrons l'établir king
gouverneur et défenseurs du pays et
aussi pour ceux qui n'étaient descendues
de la lignée de trois comme il était ils
furent tout un peuple et une jante
[Musique]
les grandes chronique de france offre
ainsi un récit cohérent de la fondation
de la france sic en brie et le berceau
originel duquel sont sortis d'abord les
gaulois guidés par ivor puis les francs
guidés par marco mire
puisque le lieu d'origine des gaulois et
des fronts et si cambouis une question
se pose où et si cambrai
s'agit-il d'un lieu géographique ou
métaphysique au baptême de clovis
saint-rémy s'adressera au roi par
l'apostrophent si caen pourtant jamais
les membres de la tribu de clovis mme se
sont désignés eux mêmes par ce nom les
rares évocation d'auteurs anciens ne
donne guère d'indications césar parlait
d'une certaines tribus dessus cambre le
long du rhin mais son témoignage
imprécis n'offrent aucune piste
peut-être la réponse est elle dans le
nom même de sic en brie pourrait-il
s'agir d'un et celtique
si qu'ambri fait penser à cambrai la
cambre y est l'ancien nom du pays de
galles
selon l'étymologie combrit découle de
com qui signifie commun et deux brebis
territoire
la comberie veut dire le territoire
commun plus simplement la patrie
si combrit possède deux orthographes
avec ea ou avec y
le cid si qu'ambri pouvait être un
préfixe qualifiant en gaulois su
signifie bon
le nom de sic en brie serait formé
dessus comme groggy qui se traduit alors
par le bond territoire commun plus
simplement la chère patrie
or que dit la légende la légende fait
précisément de sic en brie la patrie
originelle des francs et des gaulois
les coïncidences ne s'arrête pas l'art
est la première ville de l' empire
romain conquise par les francs et
cambrai dont la consonance avec sic en
brie et évidente
tout se passe comme si un même nom
celtique signifiant la patrie faisait
passer les francs légendaire de sic en
brie à cambrai la même question
linguistique se pose pour le nom de la
pannonie de quel lieu s'agit-il
au 19ème siècle l'historien godefroid
kurth mettait en garde contre
l'homophobie de certains lieux qui
indique parfois une mauvaise piste aux
chercheurs
pendant des siècles entier le danemark
n'at-il pas été désignée sous le nom
dacia simplement parce qu'entre ddas y
ait des dani il y avait une ressemblance
fortuite ne nous empressons donc pas de
traduire pannonia par congré qui sait si
la tradition franck ne se figurer pas
sous ce nom un tout autre pays la da ci
étant situé en roumanie
on aurait pu en effet il cherché
longtemps des danois germanique la
légende plastique en brie en pannonie
mais l'élément important et il le pays
supposés la hongrie ou bien le nom même
de pannonie et ce qu'il pouvait évoquer
en langue celtique
il existe un mot gaulois très proche de
pannonie paint in us est l'ancien nom du
grand st bernard
ce passage naturel entre la gaule et
l'italie
c'est de paint in us que les alpes
penning tiennent leur nom en gaulois
pedneault veut dire sommet tête
quant au suffixe il indique une
divinisation
[Musique]
ainsi p nu signifie le sommet divin
un passage de l'historien romain qui
clivent indique l'origine du nom des
alpes et nine et la divinité de la
montagne ce mot les montagnes à l'appel
pena du fait qu'il est sacré en son
point culminant
durant le haut moyen âge l'éclair avait
perdu le sens premier du mot gaulois
paint in us pourtant selon faisait
partie de la tradition orale du pays
alors il lui cherche une localisation
terrestre
quand sur les vieilles cartes de
géographie le nom de pannonie sauf
written les moines cru avoir localisé le
lieu d'origine des français venus furet
interprété en pannonie telle est la
force de gravité d'un mot connu sur un
homonyme incompris cela expliquerait
aussi pourquoi proviendrait de pannonie
non seulement les francs mais aussi le
plus grand sein d'oxfam et l'apôtre de
la gaule saint martin
sic en brie en pannonie voulait
peut-être dire en langue gauloise la
chère patrie sur le sommet divin il est
connu que les dieux céleste ont toujours
vu leur demeure sur les auteurs tels
ceux des grecs sur l'olympe
c'est lors de la christianisation que
l'espace métaphysique des anciens
immortel a comme atterri dans l'histoire
de nos rois
après le baptême de clovis la mémoire
populaire a transféré les anciens
exploits des dieux de la gaule sur des
rois francs et ce transfert se fit
d'autant plus facilement qu'il y à deux
mille ans les druides eux mêmes affirmé
que les seules tu venais d'eau delà du
rhin et même de 3 ainsi est née la
mythologie de la france dont la mémoire
identitaire remonte à l'aube des temps
tout au long de l'histoire les forces
mystérieuses de l'imagination ont guidé
les sommes misées légende influence les
sociétés et en sons comme le souffle
spirituel
au cours de sa destinée chaque nation
s'efforce d'atteindre la source oublier
des temps on y cherche d'anciens titres
de gloire ou un paradis perdu
[Musique]
le moyen âge et la renaissance se sont
passionnés pour les origines troyenne
des francs et des gaulois
[Musique]
la quête d'un passé sacré donne à toute
communauté un sens à l'avenir c'est la
continuité de notre destinée nationale
[Musique]